as we all try to make sense of season
two's huge cliffhanger there's one
character who may be much more important
to the future of the umbrella academy
than any of us realize
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining why harlan could
well be a secret member of the sparrow
academy and i'll be revealing hidden
clues to his potential backstory with
the commission
obviously spoilers ahead so take care in
harlan's very last scene of season 2 we
see him leaving dallas with his mother
[ __ ]
and although vania had seemingly
withdrawn the power she transferred to
him when he drowned the final moment
left us in no doubt that harlan has
retained some of her telekinetic powers
and we saw him levitating his little
wooden bird a strong pointer to a
connection between him and the sparrow
academy but what would be harlan's role
in the sparrow team
although he's just a young boy in 1963
56 years later in 2019
harlem would be well over 60 years old
so
rather than him being recruited by
hargreaves in 1989
when the other super babies are born
it's more likely that hargreaves finds
out about harlan if the young boy's
superpowers show up again later in the
60s
they could begin to work together to set
up a new superhero team with harlem
becoming a superhero who dubs himself
the sparrow
after his favorite toy and that could
lead hargreaves to name the sparrow
academy in harlan's honor
especially if he dies on a mission
similar to young ben in the original
timeline
an alternative is that in this new
timeline the origin of the super babies
is changed and rather than being born
spontaneously as in the original
timeline
harlan is the sparrow's father and they
inherited their powers from him
the glowing lights that hargreaves
released in the finale of season 1
appear to be behind both vania and
harlan's powers given that we saw her
transfer them into harlan
so just as vonya was able to reproduce
her powers in another person
what's to say that harlan can't do the
same and pass on his powers to others
too
if harlan were to die as i mentioned
before he could still live on inside the
mysterious green cube that floats
alongside the sparrows on the balcony in
the finale
now i know this may sound crazy but it's
not outside the bounds of possibility in
the bonkers world of the umbrella
academy where we've already had a
talking smoking goldfish in a fish bowl
attached to a robotic body we know
harlan has telekinetic powers and can
therefore make objects float so it's
interesting that the cube not only
floats into view but it also glows
inside hinting that it may be sentient
and curiously the first time we see
harlan in the show
he's actually wearing green indeed
there's a precedent for something
similar to this in another superhero
show
doom patrol in that dc show the body of
cliff steel was destroyed beyond repair
in a car accident
however his brain was salvaged kept
alive and put into a robot body turning
him
into robot man and the doom patrol
comics were a major influence on gerard
way when he wrote the original
umbrella academy comics so even if
harlem were faithfully wounded on a
mission
hargreaves could have saved his
consciousness and transferred it into
the cube
we've already seen hargreaves save
luther from death by injecting him with
a serum that changes his physiology into
something more ape-like
and in season 2 hungary's also brought
pogo back from the dead in a similar way
alternatively harlan could still be
alive and using his powers to control
the cube himself
another possibility hinted at within the
show is that harlan becomes involved
with the commission
when his powers blew up in the
penultimate episode of season two it
showed up as a major timeline anomaly on
the commission's infinite switchboard
the handler immediately recognized the
significance of this event and she told
harlan that she could take him somewhere
that would understand and help him
i can take you to a place where you will
be properly
understood listen to i can tap into your
potential
and together just the two of us we can
do incredible things
now harlan may have only spoken a few
times in season two but it was shown
that he could understand the
conversations around him and whatever
was being said to him
so the handler's words to him may well
have planted an idea or a question in
his mind about who she was
where she came from and what the place
was she was referring to we also know in
the finale from herb
that the commission will be looking for
a new board of directors and therefore a
new head of the organization
so when harlan's powers likely show up
again on the infinite switchboard i
expect the commission to take an
interest in him again
he may even get recruited to work for
them similar to how the handler
recruited five as a commission agent in
the first season
in fact harlan's name may actually be a
reference to andrew harlan the
protagonist from isaac asimov's the end
of eternity
a novel which has some incredible
parallels with the umbrella academy
the end of eternity is a time travel
story in which people call the eternals
run an organization that exists outside
of time and manipulates events
throughout history to create and
maintain what they see
as an optimum timeline that will bring
about the maximum good for humanity
ring any bells so far so commission
controls time more like we maintain the
correct timeline but
basically yeah we are tasked with the
preservation of the tying continuum
through manipulation and removals
in asimov's novel harlan is an eternal
and technician who makes modifications
to the human timeline
and i can't help but think that the
connection between the umbrella
academy's temps commission or temps
eternalis as it's called in the comics
and azimov's eternals hints at harlan
ending up at the commission in some way
maybe even taking charge and if he does
perhaps he will become instrumental in
ensuring the commission follows a policy
that leads to the creation of the
sparrow academy
another small but important detail from
the finale of season two
is that when [ __ ] and harlan leave
texas for california we see them
crossing the state border into new
mexico
new mexico is of course on route from
texas to california but it's interesting
that the series chooses to show us this
particular moment in the journey
because it means that [ __ ] and harlan
could be passing near the site of the
roswell ufo incident which has been the
subject of numerous ufo and alien
conspiracy theories
the umbrella academy already made
allusions to various jfk assassination
conspiracy theories in season two
and given the reveal of hargreaves as an
alien the show may be hinting at
something strange happening to harlan as
he passes through new mexico
could he be intercepted by the
commission or somebody connected to the
now deceased majestic 12 or some other
nefarious organization
we've got numerous possibilities
pointing towards harlan either setting
up or helping form the sparrow academy
perhaps even being the cube member of
the team but what could suggest
that he will be a future antagonist in
the series well it's interesting to note
that at the end of season 2 when new ben
arrives on the scene he's immediately
rude and hostile towards the umbrella
team
dad who the hell are these [ __ ] we
know that reginald hargreaves is a cold
and unforgiving father as we've seen in
flashbacks from both seasons
and he even admitted to luther that he
has a deep dislike of children
and given how he reacted to the umbrella
academy that he met in 1963
i've seen about enough it seems clear
that he must have decided to form the
sparrow academy with very different
children
given the way new ben has turned out in
comparison to the much more gentle bend
from the first two seasons it seems like
this new group may have grown up with a
nastier and colder edge to them which is
why the sparrows and possibly harlan may
turn out to be season three's
antagonists
on the outside they may seem to be
superheroes but behind the scenes they
may have a darker side
similar perhaps to the corrupt nature of
the superheroes and the boys
we should also remember that harlan
inherited vonya's powers and she became
an antagonist in the first season due to
the way she'd been treated by her father
and family
in situations of extreme emotional
distress vonya's powers can spiral out
of control
something we also saw when she was being
tortured by the fbi in season two
harlan also went supernova when he
accidentally caused the death of his
father
after his powers deflected a bullet into
carl however after vonia extracted the
lights from harlan he seems to be calmer
and more in control
but we don't know whether he can keep
the powers in check if some kind of
tragedy strikes again
what if the authorities come after [ __ ]
and him when they investigate carl's
death and try to take her away from him
for instance
of course i don't think it's at all
certain that harlem will end up on the
dark side especially because in all of
his season two scenes with vonya he
seemed sweet and sensitive
still there is something a little
ominous about the final scene
as we see him and [ __ ] cross the border
into new mexico
and if you want to learn more about the
various conspiracies that were
referenced in season 2
as well as all of the secret sparrow
symbols hidden throughout the season
tap here to watch my things you missed
video or follow the link in the video
description
so who do you think harlem will turn out
to be in season three
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video a
thumbs up is hugely appreciated
tap left for a full explanation of
everything in season two
including the ending the umbrella
academy's time travel rules are
multiverse who the sparrow academy
really are
and all the new powers that were
revealed thanks for watching and see you
next time yippie kai movie lovers